So what are these benchmarks? They are programs
and input data that users or companies have
agreed upon will be used for performance measurement.
So pretty much either a consortium of companies meets
and decides that these are the programs and
input data that we will use for performance
measurements. Or a group of people, who is
concerned about some performance issue, will design programs and
data and allow others to measure performance on
that type of a problem using those programs
and input data. Usually we don't have just
one benchmark program, we have a benchmark suite,
it consists of multiple programs along with their
input data. Each of these programs is usually
chosen to be representative of some type of
applications. So for example, we will not have
ten different compression programs in a benchmark. We will usually
have one or two because we think that those one
or two are probably accurately representing the behavior of the
other compression programs that we didn't put in the benchmark suite.